I'm Roman meta director of power
computing technology at Wolfram research
I will talk about persistence and
initialization I will show the new 11.2
features for stowing information at
various locations and how to use it for
kernel initialization
good afternoon I would like to tell you
about the new feature of the 11.2
version of the Wolfram language that was
released a couple of weeks ago and it's
all about persistence and initialization
of kernels so persistence is a unifying
access layer on top of various storage
locations where you can store values
that persist beyond the end of the
current session you could think of
storing something in a local file or in
a cloud object and there are others like
front-end sessions and another feature
is that these locations are searched in
a certain order so you can set it up so
that it can find values that exist
locally before those global defaults and
things like that and the main use of
persistent values is initialization
that's intended to replace or improve
the old system of using any dot m-files
where you put those commands that should
happen whenever you start a new kernel
so there are a couple of new terms to
learn a persistent value that's the
smallest thing we deal with persistent
value has a name and a value and the way
you define a persistent value is by
assignment as I've done here and then
when you ask for it as I'm doing down
here then it will return that previously
defined value that's exactly the same
thing as you are familiar with symbols
within the language you define a symbol
and whenever you use it you get back
that value but as soon as you quit the
kernel that symbol is gone but that
persistent value will still be around so
the next
I'm you launcher colonel you don't need
to do that assignment you will
immediately retrieve that persistent
value.now persistent values are stored
in persistent objects and persistent
object is described by the key the same
one that you see up there and the
location where that object is stored
now I haven't said anything down here
there's obviously a default location
that's the value of that variable dollar
persistence base and so if I ask for
that persistent object I will get it
back we know the difference here up here
means persistent values are like symbol
if you ask for them you get the value
you it's very difficult to do something
to the symbol itself because it's like a
slippery fish whenever you touch it it
goes away and the way you solve it with
symbols is that sometimes you use the
symbol name in quotes and here the same
relationship is between persistent
values and persistent objects and each
persistent object lives in a certain
so-called persistence location so if I
move this up a little bit then we have
the next concept of a persistence
location persistence locations are
identified by string and I will give you
a list of the ones we support in a
minute I mean there isn't a lot of
interesting stuff about persistence
location itself if you look at the
details you can see that this particular
local location is just an interface to
the local file system so these objects
live inside your home directory an
initialization is a particular
persistent value that is used to
initialize a variable so syntax is
initialization value followed by the vet
variable you want to initialize you can
give it in quotes so if it doesn't have
a value you can just use the variable
name or the variable itself
you suppose it's probably safer to do it
put it in quotes you can set an
initialization value how to use those
that's something I'll talk about a bit
later and finally another use for these
is let me see I can put this up a little
bit you can also use this technology for
stowing properties or preferences for
your package if you are also of a
package most packages have certain
settings
I mean if M Mathematica you bring up the
Settings panel you can configure it to
your needs and you might may want to do
the same for your own package then the
question is where do you store these
settings these settings should obviously
be persistent so they remembered across
sessions and so on new possibilities now
to store persist settings preferences
inside persistent values until it
commanded naming scheme is the name of
the package like the the context name
followed by the name of the variable in
this case it should be unique if you are
the only one who writes such a package
let's talk a little bit about these
persistence locations or storage
technologies there is a fairly large
number of those I mean first of all when
you start thinking about it then maybe
you can think of only one namely at the
low end the symbol itself which isn't
really persistent because it goes away
at the end of the kernel session and
then the other end you could think of
storing things inside files and that
means usually they will live on forever
but there are a couple of other
possibilities so for each possesses
location the important things are the
scope where do you see those values and
the lifetime how long do they actually
persist and symbols obviously are
limited to a single kernel session
you can assign symbols that creates it
if necessary you can ask for the symbol
symbols value and you can find out
whether symbol exists by using name q
and you can get rid of it by using
remove and so in one form another these
operations are supported for all these
persistence locations although this
seems trivial it's use it's a very
useful test case I mean one problem with
persistent objects is that they are well
persistent so you know if you put some
junk in your in e dot M file then next
time you start the kernel you will get
an error message then you have had to
hunt down where is that file and we move
it same thing happens with these
persistent values if you put something
there that you shouldn't then the system
may behave badly and so one important
test case is just use kernel persistence
and then you could just quit the kernel
and everything all your sins will be
forgotten the next level of persistence
is the front end session values stored
in the front end are visible to all
kernels running under the same front end
and the lifetime is a single front end
session in particular these values will
survive a kernel we stopped as long as
the front end is still running so that's
a way to remember something from one
kernel invocation to the next and again
if you mess up just quit the front end
and then these values are gone and how
do we do this well the front end session
supports the notion of setting options
so I can set the options in my front end
and then I can look at those and that's
how they are stored and if I know I'm
not doing it here quit and we start the
kernel this value would still be around
because I have not ended the front end
in a similar notion the document the
notebook document itself can be used to
store persistent values as a value
stored in a notebook
is visible to that Colonel that is
connected to the notebook I mean you
know how our system works we have the
front end that I'm using here for the
presentation and this particular
notebook document that you see here is
connected to a colonel that does all the
computations that I've done so far and
so these persistent values will be
visible to that particular colonel and
the lifetime now is the same as the
document and it's exactly the same as
before you can set an option in your
evaluation notebook and you can ask for
it now the interesting thing about this
location is I can now send this notebook
to somebody else by email and at the
other end if you open that document
those persistent values will still be
there because they are right inside the
notebook document so this is a very
useful persistence location I should say
that at the moment you shouldn't try to
store megabytes of stuff inside the
notebook this set options technology is
limited to small values we are working
on a new way of storing bigger stuff
inside notebooks because we have
realized that this is very useful I mean
we it's now routine to generate large
amount of data like audio capture or
video capture or you do big computation
and you want to save the result so that
the next time you open the notebook you
don't have to we do the computation so
we are working on some more efficient
storage technologies the next level up
is the local object local objects have
been around for I think two versions
they are generalization of symbols we
call them local symbols they work the
same so you can store local symbol you
can ask for the value and those local
symbols are actually backed in your home
directory there is a directory where
they are stored so you can see whether
it exists and you can remove it the
scope of these local objects is your
login domain or any
file system and the lifetime is as long
as your hard disk lasts so and of course
if you have backups then it will live on
forever the next technology oops so the
cloud object just we have cloud symbols
just the same as local symbols they're
behaving exactly the same now the only
difference is that it will take a few
milliseconds to ask for a cloud object
because that is stored somewhere on a
remote machine in the Wolfram cloud and
so the scope of these cloud objects are
your cloud login so if you go to a
different place login to the same cloud
you have those cloud objects back which
is the difference to the local objects
which if you'd go to a different
computer somewhere else you don't have
access to those so these are the storage
locations that we currently support from
the very very short lift 1 to those
local objects cloud objects that live
forever and you can now and now you see
I mean the the the syntax is almost to
say but here you say local symbol here's
a cloud symbol or before we had just
symbol or you have to set options
you shouldn't have to remember all of
this so we put designed unifying layer
on top of these technologies namely the
persistent value so you can use the same
syntax for all of those this is just a
recap of those persistence locations
that we have talked about kernel session
that's the name for the for the ones
that live in the kernel for online
session notebook local cloud now there
are some additional ones like local
shared if you install Mathematica on
your home computer then there are two
locations that where you can put stuff
one is in your home directory the other
is in a shared directory that is visible
to
everybody who uses the same software
installation but so the idea is here you
could put values that everybody in your
organization should be able to see but
it's just another form of local objects
and then there is another hidden
location the installation location that
is where you can put defaults for your
persistent values we will see examples
later on and obviously these two local
shared is usually read-only to populate
them you would have to become super user
and then you can write to the shared
location so how do we now use these
persistence locations so the main use is
for persistent values persistent value
has a name and a default location where
it is stored this default location is
the persistent space and the default is
local so this will turn into a local
object a local symbol that's how you use
it but of course you can specify where
you want to put it so you can give a
second argument to persistence value
where you can specify any of the
persistence locations so this particular
value again and you see here I use the
same key so I create persistent values
under the same name I put one in the
kernel session I put one in the front
end session and I put one here in the
default location which is as we saw the
local location now what happens if I ask
for that persistent value why does it
give me this particular one well the
reason is that it searches all these
locations in a given order and the order
is given by the persistence path so it
it searches the
session first that's why I get the 41
down here then it goes to the front end
session local local shared and
installation
note that the cloud location is absent
from the default persistence path
depending on where you live on this
planet the cloud location will mean
several hundred milliseconds delay for
each access and we did not want to put
make Colonel start up slower by that
amount of time by default so it will
take deliberate effort to put the cloud
location there if you want to use it I
will show you how to do that later on so
by default persistent value finds the
first value along that path now you can
actually tell it how it should deal with
all those values that are present at the
merging function is an option optional
argument of persistent value it will
receive as its argument the list of all
the persistent values that are actually
there and you can see we defined three
of them so the merging function receives
the list of these three values and if I
use the merging function identity I will
simply get back that list of all the
values that you have and the default
merging function is obviously as you
have seen first so it will give the
first value that implements that
hierarchical lookup where you can put
default values in your local object and
if you need to change something for a
certain time you can override that by
putting something into the Fontan
session and when you create the front
end that value is gone and you will be
back with the default value this is the
intention of this this system yes
get the list of persistent values that
is exactly the order of locations in
persistence paths yes I mean of course
you can I mean just wait a few minutes
and that will tell you how to do it
because obviously just as with symbols
you need a way to do a house
housekeeping and see what is available
and and how to delete those values in
particular so there's a lot more to come
this is just the way you would normally
use it and you will see in a minute how
you can actually see which values exist
now this merging function is quite
versatile here's another example I've
defined three values for that particular
persistent value in the kernel session
formed in session and local and all
these values are lists and as we have
seen with the merging function identity
you see all of them but you could also
use apply join as the merging function
and that would join those values
together you still see the sub lists
down here it will just join the
outermost level or if you really want
just everything you can also use flatten
and that will just give you all the list
of the innermost parts of those nested
lists and you can even do more fancy
merging with persistent values who smell
that are associations because there are
ways to merge associations in various
ways this is particularly useful for
storing preferences where you have
usually your own key value store you use
an association with all the user
settings so now the as we have seen the
persistent values live in persistent
objects and here is that answers your
question persistent objects given a key
will give you
all existing objects in all the
locations on the search path so now I
know that there is one in the kernel
session there is one in the front end
session and there is one local one and
the most important command is delete
object which will get rid of all of them
so now if I now ask for the holes again
they are gone you can also set your
persistent values to expire here I set
one to expire within 5 seconds and I
will immediately after doing that one
these three lines here so it will give
you that value then it will wait five
second and it will again ask for the
value and it says well the value is not
there anymore this is a relative
expiration time there's also an option
to give an absolute I could say this
object should self-destruct at the end
of this year now let's look at the main
use for these persistent objects and
that is for initialization so there is
one more thing to learn
it's called initialization value
initialization value takes a variable as
argument and you assign a value like
this setting this initialization value
equals 1 does not set that variable to
the value 1 it remembers an
initialization and to actually perform
the initialization you can either say
initialize that variable as I have done
here now it has been initialized
but most of the time you will use that
to have the initialization happen
automatically at kernel start which I
will mention in a few minute minutes now
the initialization values work the same
way as the persistent values so there is
the optional second argument of
persistence base and persistence paths
now of course the lookup along the path
becomes very important because you can
set a global default value for the
variable and you can override it by
choosing like the notebook location or
the front end session location to
temporarily change the lookup values and
as before these can be found now the
initialization values are persistent
values they are just use let me show you
this is very long so let me show again
the the names of these sadi that so here
the initialization value of a variable
turns into persistent value whose name
is system session followed by the full
path name of the variable so here you
can see the one that I just put up on
the screen and so the result is a
persistent object that lives in a
certain place and here I'm asking for
all the initialization values you see
the one we just put up here but there is
lots more but all of these live in the
installation location these are defaults
that have already been set up obviously
we use this system for setting defaults
for all the particular object like
persistence base and positions past
itself of course can be initialized so
that of course will then us with try a
certain order in which these happen and
there is an initialization and
initialization context which I will
mention in the mean so I said there's a
lot of stuff here but
the only thing you put yourself is this
one but it's always important to know
how to find all of the ones that exist
and perhaps delete them if they don't do
what you want them to do so now we have
all the technology for initializing
kernel in this new way the way it works
is when the kernel starts it will
perform initialize all which will then
find all existing initialization values
and for each variable for which there is
a well value it will initialize that
variable now that alone is not terribly
exciting but some of these variables
then have special meaning like dollar
initialization which after having been
assigned the value will then evaluate
its own value and so that's the
replacement for the init Atum files you
can put code into the dollar
initialization variable that will happen
every time you start the kernel I will
give you an example in a minute
so let's look at some interesting ways
to use this new technology first of all
as I've said the cloud location is not
part of the default persistence path if
you live close enough to the cloud
server and that cloud could very well be
your own private cloud in which case you
will live close to it you can change
that now what do I have to do I have to
change
persistence path so I can use an
initialization value for persistence
path and I have to put it somewhere and
I kind of put it in a cloud because
that's not yet on the path the most
useful place is a local persistent
object so that will from then on every
time you launch a kernel under the same
username look up that new setting
let me do that here let me now quit the
colonel and let me evaluate this
variable and thereby starting a new
colonel and hopefully yes there it is
and so now you can see the cloud
location is now on the persistence path
the cloud location is a cache location
which means that once it has found the
value it will keep a local copy so that
it minimizes the communication with the
cloud which can take time now here we
are as close to the cloud itself as
possible because it's actually in a
computing center right in the city so
you can't get any closer than that
so what we've done is we've defined an
initialization value for positions paths
and then whenever you start the kernel
it will find that value because it's
local on this machine and it will change
the setting of persistent paths and then
it will use this new setting of the
positions paths to look up all the other
initialization values so now you can put
initialization values in the cloud
location yes that's always at the end
yes now everything else I mean you can
of course remove that if you don't need
it no no the other one installation is
the reason is that it contains defaults
and by always putting it at the end when
you look up a value you know that you
will always have to default that saves
you an if statement to see if there is a
value otherwise so it's just a default
back at the end
another use of initialization values is
with an extension to the function once
which you may have encountered it's a
11.1 new feature once takes normally one
argument the argument is typically a
very long computation that does
something and return the result and
before that would simply store there is
the value of that the result of that
computation inside your kernel and so
when you then invoke once again then it
will not we do the computation because
it has already done it but it will look
up the cached result and now you can use
different positions locations as cashing
locations this is a into the most
interesting use case so what will happen
if I evaluate this see that I put this
in the initialization cell which you
normally put at the top of your notebook
what happens if I evaluate that
initialization set well I haven't done
this computation before so you would see
that it actually performs that
computation and then returns the result
now if I do this again it will not we do
the computations but return the old
result and moreover this result is
cached inside the notebook so even if
you send that notebook to somebody else
by email if I receive such a notebook
and I will do this initialization sell
it we'll use the previously cached
result so this is how you can avoid with
computing things which take a long time
to do now of course these values might
accumulate inside your notebook so here
is how you remove them the result of
once installed as a persistent object so
you ask for all
objects inside you a notebook
at the moment there's only one there is
the result of that it hashes the input
obviously it needs to find it so it
hashes the input and you can just delete
that and then it is gone from your
notebook document now another useful
case for persistence and initialization
is setting up an environment in which
you can debug new code but an
environment that will go away after you
are done and so you don't forget to
change back all the values that you
changed so let me do the following so
I'm again using I'm using the front end
session for this purpose this is very
useful for this purpose because it
allows you to create and restart the
kernel and still have your special
environment but when you're done or when
it doesn't work you just quit the
front-end and then everything is
forgotten and you have a clean slate
again
so I set an initialization and
initialization sorry sometimes the mouse
initializations should be held
expressions these are the things that
will be evaluated when the kernel starts
so what I want to do is when the current
starts it should add a certain directory
to your path that's where your code
lives which you are debugging right now
and you also want to read the package
that is under development and so you add
that package to the dollar
initialization context so these are both
initializations let me do that now I
quit the kernel but not the front-end
now I ask for dollar paths which will
start a new kernel and hopefully the new
directory is on the path the contact
staff contains that particular package
that I mentioned let me move show you
hopefully on the same screen here my
package and that package has been wet so
if I ask for all the symbols in my
package there's just one that is now
available so you can very quickly turn
around in your debugging session you try
out things change the code quit and
restart the kernel and you are back in
action within a few seconds and if
you're done there just with the
front-end and everything will be gone
we've talked about merging functions
before you can equip certain
initialization values with your own
merging functions the way to do this is
when you set up an initialization value
you also specify the default merging
function so here I set the default value
for this variable to be the empty list
but they also said the merging function
to be flattening if I now specify it if
a second value for this variable at the
front end session location and if I ask
for that value it will flatten the two
values found now this one obviously
doesn't contribute anything it's a good
default the empty list and this will now
happen automatically so every time you
start the kernel your variable will have
that particular value so this is useful
for values like reviews before lists of
things where you don't want just the
first of them but you want all of them
and so you use a default merging
function of flatten
there are a couple of already defined
custom merging functions and now I'm
turning to this installation location
with the defaults there is one good
example that's the system variable
dollar assumptions dollar assumptions
has an initialization in the
installation location now what does this
contain well at least contains the
default value but if I now look at the
underlying persistent objects there is a
hidden way persistent objects behave
like functions or like databases you can
ask for all its internals and most of
those are internal you should not mess
with those but you can probably guess
what they do now here you see that
default merging function the default
merging function for assumptions is end
because assumptions is a collection of
boolean's and so if you have several of
them the natural way to combine them is
to end them together not to give a list
of them but to end them together you can
also see that the value the actual
default value there isn't one because
the default value says inherited which
means don't change the value just use
the special merging function you can
also see when these were created who
created them now this is a built-in
default so there's no information here
the expiration date if you set one
there's another thing called the value
pre-processing function which allows you
to make sure that only legal values are
assigned to a variable and it will also
we called the version of the language at
which the value was we was done so that
later only made me be able to migrate
all the values to new systems
there's yet one more thing namely the so
called evaluation environment
now session means what I'm doing locally
here front-end colonel or in the cloud
cloud front-end colonel but there are
other types of curves for example there
are sub kernels which are used for
parallel computing and I can set an
initialization value not only for my own
types of kernel session kernels but also
for other kernels so here I said default
value for timezone I store it locally
but not for myself but for sub kernels
if I now launch two parallel sub kernels
then my own time zone is minus five but
the time zone of those parallel sub
kernels is zero and how do you find all
those values well let me ask for all
initialization objects here local cloud
but not for myself but for sub kernels
so that's the one I just defined and
delete objects delete object will get
rid of it and in the future you will
also be it will also be possible to set
up default values for your cloud
computer computers from your desktop
the current cloud version that is
deployed in the bottom cloud does not
yet support persistent initialization
that's still under work but within a few
weeks there will be a new version that
will support it but you can already now
use the cloud persistence location on
the desktop but not yet on the cloud now
as with all everything that is
persistent I mean the kind of case that
everybody's familiar with you have a
long session you work it on something
you define some variables x equals 5 y
equals 17 and then an hour later you use
something that involves the variable X
like to differentiate with respect to X
then you differentiate with respect to 5
because you forgot that an hour ago you
defined the variable to be 5 that's the
kind of persistence problems that you
already know now of course it gets more
even worse because you can have
persistent values all over the place and
so the equivalent of the magical clear
all of global which all of you know if
you work hard enough with notebook
documents is just to ask for all the
initialization objects and in particular
I ask for all of them in all the
writable locations that I think excludes
installation and local shared and I have
a couple of them you see though you
remember this one I worked with this one
I worked with this one but the magical
thing here is just to say delete object
take the values of all of these lists of
values and delete them and now if I ask
for all the initialization objects again
they are gone
so this is how you clean up and this is
and of course what's missing now is some
nice let's say front-end to that
persistent system yes that I think now
of course the next time is not the
kernel the cloud location will no longer
be there
then of course a default the default you
cannot change you cannot delete the
defaults no you you cannot shoot
yourself in the foot time and that's the
that's that the default location is
there for exactly this purpose so that
all of these variables are guaranteed to
have a working value all you delete it
was your overriding of the default value
so if I now created we start the kernel
the cloud location well not not in the
current current in the current kernel I
haven't change anything I just changed
the initialization of the next girl that
I will start you see that it's always
one one one kind of later so like when
you write an init file you have to
create and restart the kernel to
actually see the effect of that in it
violet
now the other useful thing to do is to
if you are still unsure about the
effects of some things you do just set
position space to front end session and
of course you can also do an
initialization that is just stalled in
the front end session and these things
will work normally for all the kernels
that you start under the count front end
but once you create the front end it's
gone and you have a clean slate again so
that's a very useful thing and of course
you can also put the special setting of
position space as an initialization
itself into the Fontan session I should
probably mention that but I mean you can
just use the initialization value of
position space come upon 10 session
equals Fontan session so that would
perpetuate that folio from that session
so this is the kind of things you can do
ok sorry that was is internal stuff
that's in fact the end of the examples
section so to recapitulate persistent
values are stored in persistent objects
persistent objects are stored in any of
persistence locations which vary in
their degree of persistence and
visibility and the main use for these
persistent values is as initialization
values and as preferences for your
packages this is a new technology that
is in 11.2 on the desktop so maybe it's
not 100% it's marked as experimental
because it does change the way the
kernel starts all right I mean we have
to understand that this is a fragile
part of the system if you put an
initialization there that computes
something which takes 10 minutes then
your kernel startup time will be 10
minutes and and if you did
without realizing that you did it it's
even worse so that's why I've always at
the end excuse me at the end put in the
commands to find all values and to
delete them that's and of course I mean
as as I said earlier we we will in the
future have some ways of manipulating
this more easily like having a notebook
that lists all the values you can click
on them to delete them you can change
them and so on so there would be a nice
user interface for this new technology
but at the moment it's important that
it's out in the world that you can play
with it
that you can use it and also give us
feedback thank you
[Applause]